que sait le faire quelqu'un un berger
c'est vraiment vraiment se passe à côté
georges rémi alias hergé vous êtes le
père d'un jeune garçon qui ne vieillit
pas en fait en apparence physique mise à
part tintin est il toujours le même en
1972 qu'en 1929 date a évolué évidemment
dans la mesure où j'ai évolué et moi
même mais fondamentalement il est resté
le même
il est resté un petit boy scout je crois
que je suis resté un peu boy-scout aussi
et de ce point de vue là donc il n'a pas
changé
du point de vue des saints il est
certain qu'il était qui je crois qu'il
est mieux dessiner maintenant qu'au
début il était vraiment très sommaire
alors je crois que j'ai fait quelques
progrès dans ce domaine là donc il est
le même mais mais mais mais il a vieilli
sans vieillir
comment expliquez-vous le grand succès
qu'il a auprès des jeunes un très large
public
ça c'est un mystère pour moi aussi je
constate qu'il a du succès c'est vrai
depuis longtemps ce qui m'étonne encore
davantage mais pourquoi je n'en sais
rien est-ce que c'est peut être parce
que chacun chaque enfant peut se
projeter lui-même là dedans
vous savez que le jour où on a fait un
jour un film à comédien au début on a
cherché le petit personnage qui serait
qui pourrait incarner tintin et on a
reçu une lettre
le producteur du film a reçu la ligne il
a fait une enquête il ay la question et
il a reçu une lettre d'un petit noir un
jeune noir disant moi je pourrais jouer
tintin
moi je suis tête il ne voyait pas la
différence de couleur de peau il avait
pris 7 est identifiée en fait atteinte
et c'est peut-être c'est une des raisons
du succès mais les autres je suis
vraiment incapable de le donner
c'est le deuxième dessin animé que l'on
va voir tintin et le lac aux requins
après j'y crois tu atteins et le temple
du soleil quel est votre participation
elle a surtout consisté à l'élaboration
avec
greg du scénario et ensuite dans les
décors il ya eu les modèles cheese aussi
un mot barbare signifie qu'on a désigné
les personnages de face de dos de
profils de trois cas de façon que les
animateurs puis s'en servir pour faire
leurs animations
c'est un premier point il a fallu créer
des personnages nouveaux qui est ton qui
ont été faits dans mes studios
il a fallu faire les décors surtout
qu'ils ont été défaits également dans
mes studios
tous les corps ont été destinés non pas
colorier mais destiné aux studios hergé
ça y est ma participation